歡迎收看李台大人秀
最受歡迎的教學單元標谷在線的
這個單元已經做了很長一段時間
朱老師常常說
都已經快要不曉得能教大家什麼了
但是技術現行說簡單是簡單
還是要很多的步驟反覆的看
所以我們設計了特別單元
什麼叫特別單元
接下來
會來告訴大家
我們都說進場做多
你會覺得有好多種方法
好像軍線糾結突破也是啊
對不對
回後買上帳也是啊
到底做多有多少種方法
我們幫您整理一下
有十大進場做多的訊號
或者是說他的型態
今天先來講前三種好不好
我們會分三集來講
所以這三集非常寶貴
如果你不確定
進場疊這三集一定要好好地看
好 朱老師 我們現在已經有點反普歸真
對不對
因為我們之前講過很多嘛
不管是看線 看K棒
或是看型態 甚至看指標
但是學了這麼多
大家就會說是哪一集
有在講這個
到底這邊我要用哪一套
乾脆統整十個方法
假設我今天想進場
哪些訊號是進場訊號
好 我們等於把它整理一下
其實做多 大家都希望
能夠抓到最好的位置
那在基礎上我們就是兩個方法
大家二收人詳
但實際上還有很多好的位置是可以
所以我們把它整理一下
換句話說其實我們後面的教學
應該算是進階版了
已經慢慢越深入了
因為剛開始讓大家知道
什麼叫技術分析
然後因為很簡單
所以你一聽好像很容易
但實際上你做一做又發現
好像又不是很容易
好像還是出很多問題
那就是技術分析
它本來就是有分好幾個層次
那我們現在把它更深入一點
那我也是這樣規劃
希望大家如果你前面都有去看過的
那現在就再深入一點
多了解一些 能夠幫助你
那我們今天來講
做多的進場位置
大部分的傻戶都還是以做多為主
做空的在比例上還是比較少
那當然我們後面有時間 有機會
我們當然把做工的也整也可以
好 那我們來講做多
實際上最重要的兩個
就是我們在前面教學教過的
那我們今天給大家做詳細的一些
一些這個內容的規定
因為有的時候
大家可能是一字半解
只聽到一個名詞 回後買上漲
其實回後買上漲
它的要求是蠻嚴格的
所以你才會做到機率比較高
如果你只是聽到一句話
回後買上當你就去買
那你就會覺得
怎麼有時候就買不到了
以為只要回檔上當都能買不是這樣
那是一個口訣嘛
但是在這個位置大家一定要注意
所以我們今天介紹的第一個位置
就把它複習一下回後
兩個位置
一個是盤枕突破
一個回後買上當
那我們複習一下這個盤枕突破
那盤枕突破
那你要去買有幾個要件
你稍微去加強一下
可能你做到的機率就很高
那第一個突破的這個紅K
一定要很漂亮
就是說不要長的一個長上隱線
長下隱線
或者甚至於還是一個小黑K
那這種看起來
就好像沒有那個力量
所以我們要K線
要價漲量增現實的訊號
我看到的突破
因為我們都有講過
今天要突破的話
大概在一點鐘
或12點多一點
你大概應該就很確認了
今天的收藩是突破的
那這時候你再來確認
他有沒有量有沒有增
對不對
如果他今天又是有量的突破
那比無量的突破
一定要比較強嘛對不對
那還有這個線
我們說現實就是
實體的紅K棒
而不是有上下銀線
有那個類些比較
比較雜亂的線
所以我們叫現實
那價漲當然你突破價一定要漲
你價跌怎麼會突破
而且突破盤整的上景線
就是要確認突破
那第二個量要比昨天的量
1.3倍 這個大概就有出量了
比如說昨天還沒有突破是1000張
那今天有突破了1300張 1500張
那如果有2000張其實是更好
因為這叫旗漲點
如果高漲當然就要小心
那第三個K線要收中長紅K的實體棒
那大概了最少要2%的漲幅
你今天至少要漲到2%
如果太小的話
這個還是等明天會不會續工
會不會有量幀再來決定
你的成功機率會比較高
我們要求的條件越多
就代表這個位置
符合的話
你應該做到的機率就比較高
這只是必勝位置一
就有三件事情要看了
對 就是進場的這根紅K
以後你回後買上的紅K這樣子
就是說我現在要買嘛
所以我希望市場的攻擊力量要比較強
這樣子我買上去才有機會繼續漲
而非要我一買明天就不漲了
這個就不是理想了
那盤枕呢
我們第一個是盤枕的突破
那盤枕也要看一下位置
有不同的盤枕
比如說空頭
它是空頭的低檔
那空頭的低檔如果盤枕突破
那就變成反轉多頭
就變成底底高頭頭高
可是你要檢查一下
如果這時候月線還沒有站上
甚至於月線還在下彎
你還是忍耐一下不要做
你一看 這個不是多頭嗎
也是盤枕突破
但是這是底部的盤枕突破
還有均線還沒有做好
那你就忍耐一下 不要做
等下一次 等他下一次回後上漲
均線做好 你再來做
這個就不宜買進
國家在越線之上
但是越線上揚 進場做短多
因為你上面還有一個極限
所以這個時候你可以做一個短多
這是底部的盤整
意思就是說你前面都是空頭
都一直疊 這個底部盤整
如果在多頭的盤整 就是出身段
底部已經上來了
然後進到盤子
那這時候你軍線 市線 多牌
周線也站上二十了
那這時候你可以短線
或中長線做多
你的勝率大概八成
這個勝率八成
就是指盤子突破的這一根
而且又符合剛才那三個條件
你大概有八成都可以做到
八成已經很高了
在我們做股票裡面
勝率到八成的都要出手的
因為你很難等到
有人給你保證百分之百
好 都不能保證的
對啦 至少有八成勝率
那有兩成就用停損來控制他
好不好
那如果他是第二波上漲
因為你回頭看可以看得出來嗎
未來看不到嘛
可是你前面會看
他已經漲了一波
又漲一波 現在進盤整
那這時候突破大概有七成的勝率
還是很高
第二波還是有七成
這個在我們的倒數理論裡面有講
因為這個叫出生段
這個叫主生段
這個盤枕突破這種陌生段
如果在陌生段的盤枕就要小心了
第一個骨架一定很高了
可能都已經長一倍了
第二個你會發現
這個地方的盤枕量特別大
那就要特別小心
如果盤枕突破
有可能會出現假突破
那這時候你就要做好一些
停損、反手這些策略
心理做好準備
換句話講在陌生段盤整的突破
那個勝率只有5成
好 勝率就變低了
一半一半嘛
所以還是要早一點出手對不對
要一半一半
就是說它突破了
你也要預防萬一它不漲
你也要趕快跑
因為這個最重要就是股價已經太高了
這個地方有突破就預防假突破
所以我們都講
盤整突破可以買了
那你再看一下
你的盤整在哪個地方
哪個地方的盤整
那你這樣的深思熟慮
我相信你突破進場
就不會亂進
朱老師他們也會問
我要看多長
我要回頭看多長
看一年嗎
看兩年嗎
還是看今年
沒有 看你的底部
你的底部可能是上禮拜才打的
前面都空
像最近很多的舞票
不是疊身的底部
然後現在又勾起來
那現在長起來叫第一波
現在不長了 進到盤整了
那叫出身段的盤子
所以看位置
好 我們看這支股票
我們就看 你在這裡盤子
那我就看你前面
要你前面都是在打底
對不對 都沒有漲
那在你打底這是多頭
多頭確認進到盤子
所以你在這裡做
成功率在八成以上
如果你看這個你一做
就連拉兩顆漲停板
所以你一定獲利的
我們講成功率就是沒有停順
你有賺錢
那賺多賺少就不一定了
就看主力是怎麼做的
好 那這個就是一個很重要的
盤整突破的位置
那你回頭又
他在盤整的時候你就可以看到嘛
這邊對不對
這上面還沒有出來
你看是不是在盤整
這邊高點 這邊高點 又跌下去
哎呦 這邊在盤整
那我就畫好上景線
所以這個就叫上景線
那今天的收盤
剛才有講喔
有沒有量 有嗎
量大概昨天的一倍
然後有沒有線有股價漲
然後紅K實體棒
這個就最標準的
那如果你要再加一個
我剛剛講條件越好就越好
KD指標也是多頭排列
所以你大概就要出手了
因為你在等也沒有比這個好了
所以你大概就可以做到
那當然盤整突破
因為你原來就多頭
所以盤整突破均線都不會有問題
這都是多排 均線多排
所以這個你就知道
這是一個好位置
買進去了當然你就要做好你的操作的紀律
也要做好 挺順 挺力都要做好
我們今天只討論進場的位置
我們只討論進場
對 那後面 出場下次再聊
後面我們再講出場 再操作紀律
再講操作的紀律好不好
那這支股票也一樣
在這個地方均線糾結
糾結 對
那你看股價漲到這
其實沒有漲多少 溫溫吞吞
因為這一段都沒漲
對 溫溫吞吞
那現在進到盤子
這個叫頭頭堤
這個叫堤堤膏
這個紅K叫堤堤膏
那現在又疊
所以是盤枕
盤枕突破
大量有嗎
有量 有架 有線
然後有KD指標
所以你又做到了
基本上你都是成功的
所以這些位置
這個盤枕突破
我相信就已經介紹很清楚
以後你看到了盤枕
因為盤枕都有一段時間
是 應該你都有時間去等他的
在等的時候你就去觀察一下
前面怎麼長的 後面怎麼長的
那甚至於這隻骨架是不是現在的熱門骨
對 如果熱門骨又進到盤整 那更好
你更要等他突破趕快買
因為他就是修正嘛 修正完了又會再長另外一波
好 進場位置一盤整突破 對不對
進場位置 哇一個盤整突破我們就教很細了耶
對 因為這樣你才叫做技術分析
我們常講技術分析的熟練
你才是真正的很熟練
好 那在第二個位置
大家都會背了回後買上掌
回後買上掌就等於朱老師
朱老師就等於回後買上掌
對 回後買上掌這五個字
主要是為了讓大家
能夠順口比較好練
是 但是你還是要詳細
知道他的這個淚含
他的淚含
好 回後買上掌一樣
他的紅K我們剛剛已經講過了
他的紅K一定要符合那三個
有量 有價 有限
然後多頭回檔指碟
沒有跌破前面的低點
出現上漲的中長紅
所以他有第一個條件
回後不能跌破前面低點
這個是第一個條件
第二個條件
一定要有紅K的上漲
這邊有量 有價 有紅K實底棒
基本上這個就是標準的
回後買上漲
回後買上漲又來了
有的同學買就成功了
有的同學也怎麼會
或者有些買了就會大漲
有些就漲得比較慢
因為這個跟什麼有關
跟回檔的幅度有關
我們回檔都不能跌破前提
可是有人回到跟前提都差不多了
有人只回來一天就上漲了
所以回檔幅度越小
這個力量越強
比如說你看到三支股票
今天都是回後買上漲
那你要買哪一支
買回最少的
我又沒那麼多錢
又不能每支都買 對不對
對 一支是回到這裡的回後上漲
一支是回二分之一的
一支是大概三分之一就上漲了
所以你要買這個
回檔最小的這一支股票
我跟你講人性
你都會想要去買最弱的
因為看起來便宜
對 因為回了越多
價錢越便宜
但是你想想看
你跌到這上面
全部都被套牢了
套牢壓力很大
你跌了五天
有五天被套牢
我這個只跌了兩天
所以我只有兩天被套牢
那我今天又是放量
又有紅K
所以我兩天的壓力
比較容易克服
那你這個其實要注意
八成都過不了前高
所以我們常講回檔太深了
你回檔深很容易看毒
就看得出來
這你一定是黑黑黑黑
哇他一頭都是黑的
連山黑我們叫連山黑
所以你在這裡買
80%都過不了高點
你還要準備跑
當然你大概也不會賠一錢
因為我不過我就沒有賺到而已
可是我們希望一買就過高
然後就充馬
這樣才會賺到錢
所以這是第二個回賣
買上漲的一個重要觀念
盡量買強勢股
因為我們本來就講
股票是強者很強
沒錯
弱者很弱
對
你買了沒有賠錢
可是也脫脫拉拉的
脫離帶水的
不動就不動
對對做得凡死了
看到別的股票一直漲
心都 心都凡死了
所以你要選回檔比較
比較幅度小的
幅度小的比較強勢的
好 第三個
你做回後買上漲
就要注意了
因為你回後買上漲
前面一定有個高點
這個叫回來的高點
這個高點就是壓力
所以回後買上漲一定要過壓
那我剛剛有講
你已經回到幾乎回到三分之二了
所以萬一沒有過壓
請你趕快離開
回後買上漲沒有過錢高
就進入盤子
那進入盤子會耽誤你的時間
你可能一兩個禮拜都沒有獲利
那一兩個禮拜如果別的股票
會漲很多的
所以我的意見
做短線的人不要爆盤子
除非你是報長線
那長線又不可能在這買
一定是在底部
長線的人可能就不會看那麼細了
他一定有他家族的利益
因為你在底部買 你長到這都
我已經賺三四十%了
你只要盤著我就不管你了
除非你變空頭
我才要考慮離開
所以做短線的人
你回後買上漲
不過錢高就錢你一定要買
這是第一個要注意的
第二個要注意的
萬一回後買上漲
跌破月線
它沒有跌破前提喔
所以它還是符合的喔
沒有跌破前提嘛
可是你回後買上漲
這根紅K要站上月線才可以買
因為你沒有站上月線
月線沒有辦法給你支撐
換句話講
你可能上漲的力道就沒那麼強
所以這是第二個要注意的
第二個其實就是
格蘭幣八大法則
格蘭幣的進場位置
它就是跌破月線要上月線
所以這裡是買點
這一點稍微注意
有的人可能一看到這個就去買了
可是因為你月線沒上
明天可能就有一些震盪
或甚至於這邊就會下來
那就你當然就要停損
你不能讓它一直下去
這是我們回後買上漲的注意事項
所以我們只有五個字
但是你要注意的事情
你要注意很多
其實我剛也講
這是為了讓你能夠更精進
對不對
你以後股票越做越好
你才會有興趣
否則每次背了五個字
怎麼都買不到
或者賺不到錢
好 那我們來一樣看一下
這都很標準的
這是一支多頭上漲
那多頭上漲你有做到
當然按機率你就走了一趟
跌破五均
你沒有做也沒關係
我常講這是第一段
那你就等他回回來
有了 回後買上漲
有紅K 有大量
然後把昨天的高點也突破
再檢查一下軍線
軍線也很好
還在月線上吧
這個地方就是回後買上漲
對不對
那這一個顏色武軍
各位要仔細看
不要看到黑K就以為不好
這個黑K沒有跌破武軍
所以你就顏色武軍
顏色武軍一直抱這邊跌破
所以這個叫回檔
假如你這一段又沒有做
那現在有回檔
如果我有做
提不過武軍我要賣嗎
短線賣
如果你是底部做的
我們長線就報20均
你一直報到現在都沒有賣
所以你這個跌破也沒有賣
反正我也是賺錢
短線的我在這裡賣了
空手的我又有機會了
這個十字線跌破五均
這個紅K就叫回後買上漲
當然在月線上
然後站上五均
然後有放量
然後KD也上來了
這邊又做到一段
那這個就是標準的回後買上漲
標準的回後買上漲
但是一樣啊
回後買上漲其實
跟我們剛才的盤整突破一樣
也要看位置
為什麼剛剛那個都
好像買了都賺
因為那個底部才剛剛取消
李越到高漲
可是你不要怕也不要怕
因為高漲頭頭低我就賣了嘛
我已經交代你了
你不要說在這買
回後買上漲怎麼不漲
不漲你就賣啊頭頭低了嘛
如果這邊叫多頭確認
這個叫回檔
這個叫回賀買上漲
這個叫多頭缺人
我們平常上節目都跟大家講
不要追第三天 第四天
因為他會回來
回來 回賀買上漲
可是你如果說
純粹就看著圖作
那你大概就可以克服一些心理壓力
這個趙華常常講說
哎呦 這個價位太高了
我常常會講說
這個比我賣掉的價位還高
我沒有辦法買回來
他會不會不買 不買 你再回頭看
他有更高嘛
所以你後面看不到
但這個就是有量 有價有限
你就買 然後又賺
然後這個跌破五均 你有買
那現在就等下一次的回頭買上場
那你懂了這個韻律的話
那這個多頭競長就可以抓到位置
那最重要就是說
很多人都不知道在哪買嘛
所以我才把這個整理一下
讓你了解
第一個一定要多頭確認
阿格麗的愛古來了
你多回去認才能買啊
才能做多嘛
那第一波你有做
恭喜你 沒有做
所以你有回後買上漲
買了以後要守停損的
不要忘了
如果你的停損沒有破
那當然
那如果你用武軍
那你賣了
那這邊有一個回後買上漲
或者是我這你沒買
那這你再來一次
回檔買上漲
你又可以做到
回後買上漲
你又可以做到 對不對
這個幾個位置
各位在我們常常講說
鎖骨 鎖骨
我們在鎖什麼東西
對不對
就在鎖這個
我就在鎖這個位置
你來了我就做一個盤整突破
一個回後買上漲
好 這個至於什麼時候賣
我們就下次再教
一次沒辦法
一次沒有辦法教那麼多
好 所以在我們的公開版本
講了兩件事
盤整的突破
然後還有回後買上漲
剛剛朱老師說
短短五個字
回後買上漲
但是我們一解說起來要超過500個字
技術現行說簡單也簡單
但是條件要具足
不過也沒那麼難
因為看久了熟能生巧
在我們的榮耀班裡面
教教第三種進場的位置
所以榮耀班
叮起來
我們的菁英班現在已經沒有了
現在只剩下榮耀班
所以想要學更多新法的朋友們
歡迎訂閱我們的榮耀班